metro police will be out in full force
as we usher in 2021
there are no fireworks on the strip but
there is a show at the plaza hotel
downtown
on fremont street no live entertainment
is planned tomorrow night
but you can still be under the canopy
for 25
metro police expect fewer people here in
las vegas than usual for new year's eve
but that does not change their plans for
enforcement so if you're planning to be
on the strip or downtown
remember there are several items you
cannot take glass bottles or containers
large bags luggage carts and strollers
that's all banned
metro police say in light of the
nashville bombing just a few days ago
officers will do sweeps across the
resort corridor leading up to
new year's eve and our new year's eve
show kicks off tomorrow night nine
o'clock
runs past midnight i will be at circa
along with bryan loftis and kirsten
joyce ted florendo will be downtown
we're gonna have a ton of other special
guests and performers for you so please
join us tomorrow night we have a great
lineup
we're also raising money for food banks
any money you donate it will stay right
here in las vegas benefit our community
you can find more information on
8newsnow.com just